hundreds of outsiders are descending on
the remote Nevada desert near the
military's mysterious area 51 base no
they're not space aliens but they do
come in peace they're earthlings
they are therefore the so called storm
area 51 event so this all began as a
joke on Facebook for people curious
about the site and aliens it is now
turned into a music movie and space
themed entertainment festival two small
nearby towns are preparing for possibly
thousands of people over the next few
days
decades of secrecy surrounding area 51
has fueled this speculation that it is
where the government studies aliens that
have visited earth take a listen
people that come here are committed you
know I flew six hours you guys get a
short series other people are doing it
it's more about a gathering of
like-minded people having fun sharing
stories and hopefully seeing some of
those UFOs they see out here all the
time we have some for everything even
other people interesting yeah the DEA
from Lincoln County says he might charge
Facebook for gross misdemeanor and
publishing a matter in breach of peace
exactly because the Air Force
they've also issued a warning for people
to stay away from the gates of the
Nevada Test and Training Range where
area 51 is located because they got
police posted outside government did the
government didn't even acknowledge the
existence of this base 2013 I think
president Trump would acknowledge the
aliens there if there were aliens there
with easy opportunity there's an area 52
and 50 ones the decoy
[Music]
we all want to believe